valentine's Day is one of the busiest
nights of the year for the restaurant so
if you're thinking of staying in it's
going to be cold we've got delicious and
healthy recipe ideas that are sure to be
a hit please welcome the beautiful Abby
sharp you're a dietitian and you can
have a delicious decadent tasting meal
without having all the calories exactly
I like staying in so much more than
going out all the time it's easier on
your waistline and your wallet and it's
romantic and it's way more intimate and
romantic so I always say you got to
still create that same restaurant like
experience so one of the ways I like to
do that is by kicking things off with a
little pink or red sparkling wine so
this is yellowtail they've got pink
bubbles and a red Moscato they go really
well with food all the kind of dishes
we've got going on especially chocolate
though made those delicious cup yes
peanut butter banana cup so that's what
we're gonna do yeah it's a really easy
recipe there's honestly only a few
ingredients so before we get to that
look at the menu because I'll be asking
the best for library but this is equally
beautiful you start with an arugula
salad and there's strawberries and what
else a little chef on their little goats
cheese and sliced and some sliced
almonds yup nice and then we've got
these beautiful dipped chocolate dip
figs dipped in a beautiful dark
chocolate with a little again the chevre
and Greek yogurt mousse in their little
pistachio that looks so pretty over here
that's some zucchini noodles and a
little tomato sauce so it's great
because it does lighten up that kind of
car you don't have a carb food coma at
the end of the night because when you
eat too many heavy car be food yeah
you're like hang out later yeah exactly
except did you steam these or they need
to very very slightly steam okay mm-hmm
and then for the entree yes that is a
beef tenderloin with a little port
reduction with some dark chocolate
eighty-five percent I like a more lace
on it kind of like that yeah but it's of
course it's a it's very light and very
healthy and still feels indulgence okay
now to make these gorgeous cuts you have
to melt down chocolate a lot of people
fear this because it can seize how do
you avoid exactly so I always say you
know you use the best quality chocolate
so for this I'm using green and blacks
organic burnt coffee dark chocolate all
organic fair trade I love their bean to
bar philosophy so keep it on a really
low heat and you just want to put about
an inch worth of water into the bottom
of that pan
it's gonna simmer really low and slow
and gently melt it because you don't
want to scorch it it's so high quality
so it's not boiling it shouldn't be
boiling yeah it should be very lightly
simmering and you keep it open like this
yes okay and I'm adding some coconut oil
yeah so this just helps smooth it out so
that you kind of can evenly distribute
the chocolate in your peanut butter cup
okay so I've got these cute little molds
these are mini ones I've got a little
bit bigger because sometimes you need a
little extra something something you you
know won't stick you don't have to
grease those know they're silicone so
really easy nonstick I'm just putting a
touch into the bottom of each one of
these so this is after you've melted
down the chocolate you just add a little
dog yeah like honestly you don't want to
overdo it because it's uh it's so easy
to over fill these and you want to leave
space for of course your delicious
filling and they look so professionally
done well it's so easy even you you know
you can pull it off very easily so into
our filling we've got some all-natural
peanut butter no sugar at it no salt
added you can use almond butter whatever
you got you know if you if you're more
of an on-again if you are allergic to
peanuts you can use the kind of the wow
butter or whatever whatever you like
juice we've got a little bit more of
that that coconut oil again I just kind
of smooth things out a Berlin will be on
our website because I definitely
salivating right now vanilla and the
kind of way we lighten this up is a
really ripe banana we don't add any
extra sugar to this so that's the sweet
pass the sweetener and honestly that's
all you need that's really all you need
so you blend that in blend it together
till it gets nice and creamy and smooth
and negative that's your finished
product so this is the fun thing okay
you gotta put like little baby baby
birth up for the minis for the portion
control oh it's like a little peanut
butter meatball peanut butter meatball
into the bottom of each of these that
smells good and the key is really to
leave some space around the outsides
because you got to envelop that with
your dark chocolate again okay so then
you add let it let's just go in 11 done
just so everyone at home can I share so
you just do this you literally just
cover the whole thing perfect I'll your
good bit of a mess oh no it's okay let
me lick it off tour and then literally
these go back into your fridge or
freezer just to set up until they're
completely cold and then you've got
these beautiful finished product and you
finish it with a little fleur de sel oh
my
oh my gosh today Joe pops right out see
how you see this you're in our King oh
you throw it shows you're heavy you're
never gonna need it again that's awesome
right happy Valentine's Day I know that
you're engaged yeah sorry she's off the
market but how exciting thank you all
the best for more information everybody
go to breakfast television day and after
the break Jan is live at Ryerson she's
part of the new student learning center